Hi, everyone.
My name is Sean Spitzer, senior instructor for Epic Games.
Today, we're going to look at an overview for Perforce
and ICVFX and how those two work together
in a virtual production environment.
So let's get started.
What I want to point out is when working with Unreal,
you want to make sure initially,
like you saw Kevin run you through a few things,
you want to make sure that you know your server,
your username, and you also want
to make sure you're connected to the right workspace.
These are very important when working with Unreal.
And if we go to the Unreal Engine momentarily,
I can show you exactly where those settings can be found.
If you look at the bottom right corner here,
you will see that we are connected to source control.
I can click on this icon, and you'll
see that we have View Change List, Submit Content,
and Change Source Control Settings.
Now, that little menu you saw in my slide deck,
you'll actually see it here.
This will show me that I'm choosing Perforce,
but I can also choose any other version
control of my choosing.
So we're working with Perforce,
and one of the key things you want to make sure
that you are connected to is one, of course, your server,
but also you want to make sure your username
and your workspace are lined up correctly,
and you're able to find the available workspaces
within that session.
So let's go back to the slides.
You'll see also that we have other options that will pop up,
and this depends on your workflow
and where you're at when you're editing.
And what I mean by that, you'll
see in this particular menu in blue in that yellow box
that we have in our slide deck, the one on the left,
you'll notice it says Connect to Source Control.
For obvious reasons, that's because we are not.
And you'll see some of these change, again, like I said,
conditionally based on what you are doing
and your activity within Unreal.
You'll also see once you make changes,
you will see a persistent session changes show up,
as well as submit content as you're making changes.
Towards the bottom, you can also
go into Unreal within your content browser,
and you can also check out assets.
Let's go to Unreal just for a moment,
and I can show you how that works.
So say we made a change over here to one of our NDCs.
I can right click at any time and see
that this object in my overall session
is connected to source control.
I can check it out, I can refresh,
I can check my history, and check the differences
against the depot.
All those things are at our fingertips.
Let's go back to the slides for a moment.
So the order of operations I want to point out
is check out your modified files, number one.
Number two, turn on persistent session changes.
And three, then you'll submit.
So you want to verify your server,
your workspace, and your stream.
That is key up front.
But then, like I said before, the order
of operations for submitting is
to check out your modified files,
turn on your persistent session changes,
and then submit your file changes.
So let me go down to the next slide here,
and we'll see that we also want
to make sure that in Switchboard
that we're going in the right direction when
it comes to our directories.
And we want to make sure that we're talking
to Unreal correctly.
So let's go to Unreal for a moment.
You'll see that we have our Switchboard open.
With our Switchboard open, we can go in here
and now check such things as our change list here,
and line this up with what we have in Perforce.
You also can check things within your settings
in making sure that Perforce
and your source control is active,
making sure that you're going
to the right engine version and path.
And you'll see here that we are connected to 5.1.
All these things need to be considered
when working with Unreal to make things flow
a lot better for you when working with Perforce.
So let me go ahead,
and I'm going to open up Perforce here for a moment,
and point out a few things when it comes
to working with Perforce.
You don't always have to set things in through Switchboard.
If you initially just want to check your files,
you can do that within Perforce by itself.
So don't think that you have to launch everything
within Switchboard to be able to get to Perforce.
You can isolate and work in Perforce first,
and then eventually go in and send things
over to Switchboard, and then send them to your wall.
All that can be done according to your needs,
and if you just need to check something
that maybe the VAD department has sent to you,
and you want to make sure before you go to the wall
and commit with Switchboard
that everything's in the right spot.
So you're more than welcome to do so.
And you can do so simply by right-clicking
and opening up that file,
or double-clicking it in Perforce.
Your depot stream, like mentioned before,
is very important that you know you're pulling things
from the correct stream.
You don't want to forget about this.
In our workspace, if I needed to find my check,
my change list, I would not necessarily go
to our actual project, but I'd go to the top
of the folder that's housing
all of our project information.
And that's where your change list information is going to be.
So I can check right over here with history viewed,
and you can also go to Windows
to get to those particular views.
And in history, I can choose my change list
and find which one that I'm working with,
and I can compare that if I'm running into trouble
within Switchboard and noticing
that things aren't quite syncing.
Whenever you're adding things to the depot,
make sure that you select all the files
within your Perforce.
And what I mean by that is say I needed
to add all of these into Perforce.
I'm going to shift select all the files,
but I also want to make sure that these sub folders
are open when I'm selecting
and make sure all the content is selected.
If you just select them and you'll notice
that there's some files being skipped over,
even though we selected the parent folder.
So you want to make sure you get everything
in the hierarchy.
So open these up, select them,
and you should be on the right path
to being able to mark them for add
and then submitting them.
Whenever you're running into trouble
and Perforce has given you a little bit of issues
and you can't seem to get all the information
to sync correctly, you can at times go in here,
not just get latest version,
but you can actually get a revision.
And when you open up revision,
you can tell it to force operation
and to load all the files in there
if you suspect that things aren't quite syncing
or talking to each other like they should.
Now, no software is perfect, including Perforce.
And then sometimes Perforce and Switchboard
may have some issues
where they're not quite talking to each other,
but this will put you on the right path
if you need to make sure that Perforce is loaded,
all your files are in the right spot,
and then you can work a little bit cleanly
and a little bit with a clear conscience
knowing that Switchboard is getting the updated data.
So let's go back to the slides.
We now see that we also have different ways
in which you can tackle Perforce.
And we talked about how you can check
and triple check the issues that you may run into.
And again, it is very crucial, you'll see it here,
that you're on the right string.
Like I mentioned before.
If you're not, you're going to find out quickly
how things are not gonna sync,
as well as Unreal will not give you the correct data.
And you may see,
hey, I partially have some files that are working
and some aren't because your files aren't lined up
with what you had previously.
So it's always good to triple check that.
You'll notice also that you have Game Sync
at your fingertips,
and we offer that for you to be able to use it.
Now is Game Sync a one all be all perfect system
in which it fixes all your problems?
No, it actually is just a shell for Perforce.
It makes things cleaner, it makes things smoother,
but it doesn't necessarily make Perforce work better
or necessarily make Switchboard magically
become even more robust and do different
or new or complete things the way that you want.
So Game Sync, again, is just a shell.
You can use it, it works great.
I've used it before.
It's a nice and clean interface,
but it really is just a shell interface
to be able to get Perforce
to sync a bit better with Unreal,
but it doesn't do anything new.
You can actually live without it,
but it is kind of cool to have
because it helps you a little bit navigating your system.